we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here's one
idea about how to avoid using the term
belief in evolution which can be a
problematic term because evolution is a
thing no matter whether you believe in
it or not let's take a listen hey David
I'll this open that you could get some
more of the real controversial
interviews they're always fun to watch
especially when they're a longer if I
know you got a lot more freedom with the
YouTube channel now oh we could put some
real nice life of course this is the
wrong voice marriage this is a voicemail
from from yesterday's show do we have
the voicemail for today's show louis i
think we do alright let's take a listen
to that one what the heck hey david this
is shane Corbett big fan your show was
calling in response to one of your
videos I've lost about what is the
correct term to address evolution and
when people ask me about it I you would
just say I understand evolution and that
you know I understand it to be a fact
that you can see it observe it and read
about it learn about it therefore
understand it I don't have to believe in
it I like that a bunch of impaired
suggest that Louis saying uh yet does
you don't have to use the term belief
because what really matters is do you
understand evolution or do you not
understand it and neither of those
require any faith they merely require
knowledge in something that exists so I
like that idea send the others if you
have them on today's bonus show is Ben
Carson's ego bigger than Donald Trump's
we will also talk about a rich old white
woman who pulls a gun on a black guy
what happened may surprise you it may
not and we'll talk about simple lasers
that can disable autonomous cars david
pakman.com slash membership and remember
the 2016 hatred mail calendars are here
and they are available at david
pakman.com slash calendar 16